monsieur kourkov bonsoir bonsoir vous
avez quitté kiev pour vous réfugier avec
votre famille dans un endroit plus
sécuritaire en ukraine pourquoi avez
vous choisi de rester de rester là nous
prennent pas ce que je ne veux pas
quitter le pays ont fait il ya beaucoup
de gens de rester à aussi à kyiv jeu les
téléphones chaque jour que je commence
le mot tendre avec des des conversations
avec mes par téléphone avec mes amis
dans les endroits différents de créer
mais mais bien sûr je suis pas loin de
la frontière avec la hongrie dans le
moment et on est ici aussi parce que je
peux en peut voyager pour
faire
collection d'argent pour les réfugiés
organiser des événements bénévoles pour
le cren ouais est-ce que vous restez
aussi pour témoigner de ce qui se passe
que vous faites là ce matin bien sûr
bien sûr j'ai écrit beaucoup de textes
chaque jour sur les événements dans nos
crânes à dole basse à 4 kg marie au
polar odessa je suis vite ou que ces
passeports ou en ukraine ouais justement
parlez-nous donc de cette guerre là ça
fait trois semaines déjà que savez vous
de la situation mario paul qui résiste
toujours oui mais c'est une ville
détruite en faire maintenant au mario
pour les remplacer dans l'histoire les
notre région de la bataille de
stalingrad pas ce que c'est c'est la
même vision cesser la même ville
détruite avec beaucoup déjà morts sur
les rues est impossible de les enlever
parce que et il y à bombardier chaque
chaque heure chaque trame mieux mais la
ville refuse de se rendre et la
mobilisation des ukrainiens cette
volonté qu'ils ont de résister ça a
sidéré le monde entier d'où vient
monsieur cocof cet esprit de résistance
des ukrainiens ce fort sentiment
national
oui j'en fais poutine à consolider la
nation
pour les ukraniens de la liberté est
plus important que la stabilité au large
à nous aussi que la vie parce qu'on ne
comprend que il n'y a pas de créer une
libre les ukraniens ne seront pas libres
rossi est comme ça c'est cette les
résistances c'est le signe qu'ils disent
ou craignant veut être les habitants
d'un pays libre et indépendant européen
et ils ne veulent pas rejoindre
l'union soviétique à nouveau ce qui
messieurs poutine cdd père ouais mais il
se bat seul un l'occident refuse
toujours de s'engager davantage on dit
que c'est par peur de déclencher une
troisième guerre mondiale
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que ça
vous déçoit
bien sûr bien sûr mais est il ya un peu
d aide militaire d et aussi pour les
réfugiés qui on a reçu déjà des pays
européens mais il ya des pays qui
en sont trop passive est en fait
continue à avoir là commerce avec la
russie c'est comme en allemagne par
exemple je crois que les politiciens
allemands ils ne veulent pas rejoindre
les sanctions plus graves contre la
russie mais en fait c'est c'est déjà la
guerre de 3e mondiale parce que par
exemple les avants de 30 minutes l'avion
militaire russe traversé la frontière
avec la pologne
ça ne va pas rester une guerre que entre
l'ukraine et la russie dans le
territoire ukrainien je suis sur le
dessin et vous pensez que vladimir
poutine que vous avez souvent critiqué
un dans vos livres ou dans des
conférences ou dans des entrevues avec
les journalistes vous l'avait critiqué
depuis longtemps est-ce que vous pensez
que vladimir poutine va aller jusqu'au
bout en ukraine oui je suis sûr des ça
parce qu il est vieux la seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est resté dans les livres
scolaires d'histoire ead russie comme
quelqu'un qui a reconstruit l'union
soviétique qui a ré construits l'un
pyrrhus et criaient à l'état d qui a
tous les autres pays ont peur parce
qu'ils ne s'intéressent pas dans les
destins des soldats russes qu ils ne
s'intéressent pas dans l'économie russe
qui est aussi cassé par les sanctions
vous vous êtes né à saint pétersbourg
monsieur courcol d'un père russe votre
grand père était un héros de l'armée
rouge et vous écriez vous écrivait
d'ailleurs vos romans en russe excuse
c'est difficile de vie cette double
identité en ce moment pour vous c'est
pas wpt je suis gêné des théocrates je
ne sais pas d'où cayenne ethniques je
suis à dubaï en politique je suis le
citoyen d'ukraine il ya plus que 7
millions et nick russe ici qui sont les
os crânien ont fait les premières
victimes civiles de cette guerre dans
l'est du pays dans le sud du pays c'est
plutôt les russophones et les russes qui
semblait supérieure d'ukraine
c'est vrai un donc vous dites les
premières victimes ce sont des
russophones justement oui à quartier
vous dans les villes de la région ces
quatre-vingt dix huit pour cent des gens
là sont aussi des grecs des russes mais
deux ou quatre
et vous dirigez aussi la section
ukrainienne du pen club international
c'est l'organisation décrivait en faveur
de la liberté d'expression qu'elle a été
jusqu'à présent la réaction des
écrivains russes qu'est ce que vous
entendez dire de skill de ce qu'il voit
de ce qu'ils savent de cette guerre oui
il ya une lettre ouverte publiée dans la
littérature nagase y est à la gazette
littéraire des moscou où beaucoup d
écrivains connus russes soutiennent
poutine elles soutiennent cette guerre
il ya aussi une lettre contre la guerre
et contre l'agression russe signé par
être par les écrans qui à partir de la
position comme vladimir sorokine de
métro big 8 rybakov boris akounine mais
la majorité des gens de la culture russe
et ils soutiennent président poutine
comme toujours et on a on apparaît sur
des messages des déçus tiennent
des côtes et des écrivains russes open
cloud vos craignent même vos amis vous
devez avoir des amis écrivains russes
non non si j'ai quelques amis je sais
qu'ils soutiennent le cren mais je parie
sur des messages de mes amis et des
russie
savez ici en occident sous certains
prônent un boycottage de l'ensemble des
artistes russes en occident pour
accentuer la pression sur le kremlin est
ce que c'est la bonne chose à faire est
ce que c'est exagéré selon vous
la majorité des écrivains au près et son
rô le boycott des cultures complètement
je pense qu'il ya bien sûr des gens qui
soutiennent notre aide et vous ne
soutient pas poutine ces jeunes il ne
faut pas les boycotter il faut soutenir
les gens comme ça nous a dit mir soro
qui y régnait parce que sanctionner
d'aider des artistes qui ont qui ont
justement manifester leur opposition à
la guerre c'est important quand même
quoi on peut pas pénaliser l'ensemble
c'est très important mais dans cette
situation je sais aussi que les
ukrainiens les écrivains de cayenne ne
sont pas prêts de parler à 6 avec des
gens avec des écrivains russes qui
soutiennent le cren parce que
emotionnellement c'est impossible
maintenant au départ les avec des
situations citoyen de la russie quand
cette guerre sera terminée pensez vous
que ce sera possible pour les russes et
les ukrainiens de vivre encore côte à
côte ou bien quelque chose s'est brisé
là avec ce qui se passe
peut-être après vente printemps et après
le chargement des politiques de la
russie
mais pas avant mais pas avant oui et ça
est ce que vous pensez vu de l'ukraine
est ce que vous pensez que là que la
pression populaire en russie va
finalement pouvoir
fragilisé vladimir poutine est ce que
c'est ça qui va arriver je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas au moment j'ai lu que 80
% des russes soutiennent président
poutine dans sa politique à propos
l'ukraine et vous là vous allez rester
en ukraine même si les bombardements se
rapproche de vous oui jusqu'à la
dernière moment ses six salles de viande
trop dans le giro bien sûr je vais
quitter le pays mais je ne veux pas
faire ça vous voulez rester oui
c'est important pour vous pour les
ukrainiens important c'est très
important pour tous les ukrainiens ne
quittez pas le pays
bien sûr il ya beaucoup des femmes et
des enfants qui ceux qui sont mes autres
réfugiés à 0 mais il ya aussi 320 milles
d obraniak qui sont réveillés ou de le
trajet pour défendre le pays
vous savez monsieur pourquoi vous avez
toute notre admiration en tout cas on
regarde jour après jour on suit cette
guerre effroyable et on vous souhaite
bon courage merci merci beaucoup
monsieur corps prof
aurait voix